[Music]
I grew up watching Rudolph the Red Nosed
Reindeer there's something timeless
about it with health my whole pitch was
let it look like it's a rankin/bass
Christmas special how we could translate
that to live-action it just felt like
something you'd never seen before I just
committed to the character I didn't want
to do too much CGI in it I wanted the
whole beginning of the film to use force
perspective in stop-motion and it's a
very dramatic juxtapositioning of this
huge athletic guy wearing this costume
built for a little wouldn't Brown puppet
and when you put him in the small sets
and around the other actors that were
shrunk down using forced perspective
like Bob Newhart just a sight gag of it
all was wonderful
and then to launch him into the new
world then the costume took on another
dimension which was a guy dressed up
like an elf walking around New York and
I grew up in New York and you could
literally walk down the street dressed
like that and people won't even look at
you twice so here I was running around
the streets of New York did yellow
tights
thinking to myself boy I do hope this
work instead of hiring a lot of extras
we shot a lot of that stuff independent
film style with a van and the camera
there was a mix of please get away from
me and some people just kind of like
hello orient so I could kind of weave in
and out but get some honest reactions
for people there are a couple people we
planted in there the guy dressed up as
Santa Claus and a red sweat suit but
other people passing him by that was all
real all that stuff of eating the dog
off the street topping on the crosswalk
that was really kind of frostbite
sometimes II drew a lot of attention I
remember there's one sequence where
we're moving through the Lincoln Tunnel
he's crawling along the side and they
just let traffic through but it added to
the danger and the fear there were a lot
of tired chirps and fender benders guys
I think people were distracted by that
the innocence was something that I
really wanted to lean into and I think a
lot of it comes from Will Ferrell's
performance it was something that played
to I strong suits as an actor in
comedians and he just loves to commit he
really knows where the laugh is in the
scene
I remember the scene in Gimbels where
Faison loved makes the announcement that
Santa's coming and he just streamed and
then the reaction and the manager
thinking his employee
screaming in his face is probably one of
my favorite moments of the movie that
was just my articulation of buddy
literally taking that piece of news a
man without a country in this strange
land finally getting to see someone
you've knows really well and it would
just be the most turbulent rash when
buddy is in the back of the sleigh and
everyone's seen in Central Park and
there's enough Christmas spirit to get
it lifted off I'm like oh I can't let
everyone see me cry here this is working
on a level that I didn't anticipate and
I knew this had the potential to beat
one of those special movies I'm really
proud of it and I could tell through
social media that it's something that
people have made a tradition I will see
pictures online of people saying hey I'm
introducing my son or my daughter to
this movie for the first time and we'll
post a picture of elf on television and
there's a little three-year-old sitting
there looking up at the screen and that
really makes me happy and it's the best
part of the job